well my friends they are putting the
people who incited the January 6th Trump
riots in charge of the investigation
into what happened on January 6th yes
there's going to be a January 6th
commission but much the same way that
Donald Trump wanted his own lawyers
investigating what happened and telling
legislatures what happened with the
election I need 11 thousand votes give
me a break exactly they are going to put
in some of the very Republicans whose
denial of the election results and
rhetoric fomented those very riots which
they will now be in get investigating
this is like what putting O.J Simpson in
charge of what happened to Nicole Brown
Simpson this is like putting take your
pick I mean it's just a wealth of
analogies and and metaphors and none of
it makes any sense but the goals of
Kevin McCarthy the House minority leader
in choosing the people that he chose for
this are very very clear Esquire has a
nice article by Charlie Pierce about
this called Kevin McCarthy is stacking
the January 6th commission with big lie
Advocates just dumping in
dumps the very people who fomented these
riots to begin with let's read this
commission while certainly better than
nothing is doomed to sink beneath the
weight of congressional inertia
Charlie writes I am perhaps not wise in
the ways of Washington but I fail to see
what sense it makes to allow members of
Congress who have demonstrated their
allegiance to the gross untruth that was
at the root of all the violence onto the
special commission tasked with
investigating the January 6th
Insurrection uh quoting from The
Washington Post that Kevin McCarthy has
selected listen to this Congressman Jim
Jordan from Ohio and Jim Banks from
Indiana to massive big lie perpetuators
as well as Rodney Davis Kelly Armstrong
and Troy Nels the lawmakers met with
McCarthy on Monday Banks said that he
has accepted McCarthy's invitation to
serve as the top Republican on the panel
quote because we need leaders who will
force the Democrats and the media to
answer questions so far are ignored I
hope you guys know what that means like
I hope you understand that the point of
selecting these people
in particular Banks and especially Jim
Jim Jordan uh is they aren't going to be
going in with the perspective of wow
there was violence who caused it and
let's hold those people accountable
that's what that's what would make sense
they're going to go in with the
perspective of wow there was some
violence and it was warranted because
the election was stolen and there was
every reason to believe that Donald
Trump may have been the rightful winner
of that election this is how backwards
this commission is going to be so the
position we're now in is one of having
to ask well okay so Republicans number
one
who are are investigating quote
investigating are perpetuators they
should be Witnesses rather than uh
investigators but number two they're not
really even going to investigate they're
going to try to perpetuate the big lie
as a justification for what took place
these people were angry and okay some
committed crimes and the court system
will deal with that but these people
were rightly angry because it does
appear as though there was funny
business here and there was funny
business there and we had all the
reasons to believe that the election may
not have been done the way it should
have been done that's what they're going
to do
so then the question is well is it worth
is it a net gain to do it at all given
that Democrats will have their
opportunity uh to show the the the
violence and all of the other stuff I
actually question it I actually question
it because the people who are going to
fall for the Republican approach to this
committee to this commission
um aren't even going to listen to what
the Democrats have to say and I really
question what is going to productively
come out of this I'm not sure if it's a
net gain quite frankly uh let's look
look at a little bit more here uh among
the five white men selected by McCarthy
three of them voted against certifying
the current president's Victory all of
them voted against impeaching uh Trump
for his role in inciting the violence
that descended upon the capital
to be entirely Fair Nails a former
Sheriff apparently was of invaluable
assistance to the Capitol Police when
the when Congress was under siege of
course uh Tiger Beat on the Potomac has
found the proper euphemisms while the
California Republican took his time
deciding between naming more experienced
members to the probe filling his seats
with fire Brands and refusing to tap any
members at all McCarthy McCarthy
ultimately chose to go with the former
route with his selections his his picks
have the committee leadership and
oversight chops to counter Democrats who
are expected to use the select panel to
hammer Trump and the Republican party
for fueling the deadly assault on the
capital in which Jim Jordan is no longer
a Firebrand if he takes this as an
attack on his previous four years of
service he might burn the capital down
so this is going to be an absolute Gong
Show we may cover some or much of it or
maybe none of it live I'm not sure
exactly what we're going to do yet but
if you were expecting that that aha
moment maybe a come to Jesus moment for
lack of a better term
where Republicans the vast majority will
say wow Trump really had a lot to do
with what happened on January 6th
um no that's absolutely not going to
happen and what will come of this
remains a real question
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies I've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over twenty thousand five
star reviews and best of all if you
don't love it you'll get 100 of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try four sigmatic is
giving my audience up to 40 percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic.com com slash Pacman the link
is right underneath this video